en fin casi el 50% de las adolescentes
dicen sentir presión por verse bonitas
los estudios también indican que los 13
años es la edad en que comienzan los
trastornos alimenticios yo tuve bulimia
durante 10 años la verdad es que lo que
más recuerdo de esa época
llorar comer odiarme y vomitar y llorar
y comer y odiarme y vomitar casi como un
mantra también recuerdo que me paraba
frente al espejo a insultarme de acuerdo
que me hacía heridas en la cabeza y en
la espalda hasta sangrar
de alguna manera no lograba convivir
conmigo misma odiaba lo que veía en el
espejo y eso afectaba mi vida en su
totalidad por otro lado yo me veía como
una adolescente normal me veía como un
adolescente feliz tenía una familia que
me quería mucho tenía amigas me gustaba
ir al colegio siempre me dediqué a la
música así que tocaba en banda cantaba
en coro iba ensayos a clases de canto
pero había algo mucho más profundo que
de alguna manera no me permitía estar en
paz
los estereotipos de belleza nos enferman
y nos dañan los estereotipos de belleza
nos hacen tan mal como sociedad pero s
siento que parece tan abstracto que
cuesta entenderlo de verdad yo fui una
de esas niñas que se enferman de verdad
yo al igual que cientos y miles creo de
mujeres me odie durante años por tener
unos kilos de más yo al igual que otras
cientos y miles de mujeres me odie por
no ser linda como las mujeres que
aparecían en las revistas o en la
publicidad estuve años en guerra con mi
cuerpo estuve años en una lucha
constante conmigo con mi imagen y me
volví frágil y me volví muy vulnerable
pasé por psicólogos psiquiatras
nutriólogos psiquiatras y todo tipo de
tratamientos y la verdad es que habían
períodos mejores pero no lograba romper
este círculo de raíz
estaba tan obsesionada con el tema del
peso que era mi único foco
me acuerdo que despertaba y lo primero
que pensaba al despertar era que con
biaggi y finalmente eso iba a determinar
mi vida mi estado de ánimo estaba
absolutamente determinado por mi peso
y como mi salud no era algo que me
importara mucho la verdad es que hice
hartas tonteras hice dietas extremas
dietas peligrosas y si hay uno y se
purga tome anfetaminas tome laxantes
tome diuréticos estaba tan obsesionada
con adelgazar que nada más no importaba
ahora que soy adulta y lo miro para
atrás de verdad y un milagro no haber
quedado con ningún tipo de secuelas a
los 29 años quedé embarazada y a los 30
años nació mi primera hija julieta a los
6 meses me embaracé de nuevo y nació la
luciana la verdad es que convertirme en
mamá fue el punto de inflexión en mi
historia
la maternidad trajo consigo una claridad
y una sabiduría que me hicieron darme
cuenta y entender que tenía que hacer un
cambio profundo de raíz yo no quería ser
una mamá que siempre estuviera a dieta
no quería ser una mamá que siempre
estuviera en desacuerdo con su imagen no
quería ser una mamá que se mirará al
espejo y se encontrara fea no quería ser
una mamá que se sintiera insuficiente
quería ser todo lo contrario quería ser
un súper referente para mi hija y bueno
lo primero era sanarme yo no y como ya
había probado todo o por lo menos eso
era lo que yo sentía trate de encontrar
un camino que nunca antes hubiera
probado y apareció en mi vida la
alimentación saludable
seguramente siempre estuvo ahí y yo no
lo había visto antes o no lo había
querido ver y empecé a hacer un cambio
empecé a dejar de alimentarme de
productos refinados empecé a dejar de
comer azúcar deje de comer productos
light y empecé a alimentarme de comida
de verdad empecé a comer frutas verduras
vegetales incluso las frutas y verduras
que siempre me habían prohibido los
nutricionistas y los nutriólogos y al
poco andar me empecé a sentir tan
distinta
empecé a tener más energía empecé a
dormir mejor empecé a tener claridad
empecé a sentirme más lúcida y sobre
todo empecé a conectarme con otra parte
mía que desconocía de alguna manera
cambiar la alimentación
reconcilió con el mundo empecé a ver
todo desde otro prisma empecé a estar
más contenta con más energía con ganas
de hacer cosas y por otro lado el foco
había cambiado de manera brutal porque
ahora estaban estas dos niñitas que
dependían de mí y yo no estaba dispuesta
nunca más a hacer nada que pudiera poner
en riesgo mi salud
y empezó a pasar el tiempo
y me enamoré de la comida sana se me
apareció delante este mundo increíble de
olores de sabores de texturas
al mismo tiempo me di cuenta que por
estas nuevas materias primas podía
preparar cosas maravillosas me empecé a
encantar empecé a sentirme con una
energía y con una fuerza que encanta
había sentido de alguna manera tener el
control sobre lo que comía me dio un
poder me dio un súper poder y eso es
súper poder se empezó a proyectar además
en montones de otras dimensiones en mi
vida como en lo laboral por ejemplo yo
siempre me dediqué al arte hasta el
momento tenía un taller de muebles me
dedicaba a la restauración hacía clases
de canto clases de música pero tenía
ganas de cambiar y de alguna manera esta
nueva energía me dio la fuerza y me dio
el coraje para reinventarme y empezar un
día para otro hacer clases de cocina
saludable en el comedor de mi casa sin
saber nada llena de miedo llena de
aprensiones y me empezó a ir tan bien
que al poco andar se convirtió en mi
principal fuente de ingreso y me empezó
a ir tan bien que al poco tiempo me
llamaron para ir a hacer un casting para
un programa de cocina saludable y quedé
y metán bien que al poco tiempo escribí
un libro y ese libro le fue tan bien que
nueve meses después de escribir un
segundo libro y a todo esto le ha ido
tan bien que ahora estoy llena de planes
de sueños y de proyectos y la verdad es
que esto no se los cuento para tirarme
flores ni mucho menos para hacerme
autobombo
se los cuento porque si a los 20 años
alguien me hubiera dicho que todo esto
iba a estar pasando a los 40 a mí me
habría parecido imposible
hacerme amiga de la comida
tener la capacidad de decidir a
conciencia como quiero alimentarme yo
como quiero alimentar a mis hijas ha
sido una tremenda herramienta
una herramienta fundamental en esta
nueva etapa de mi vida creo que como
sociedad estamos tan obsesionados con la
delgadez que perdemos el foco que
dejamos de conectarnos con lo esencial
que es nutrirnos
mientras tengamos el foco en las
calorías y no en los nutrientes va a ser
imposible que podamos salir de ahí y
esto no significa hacer apología a la
obesidad y fomentar el sobrepeso en
absoluto pero por dios que es distinto
querer adelgazar porque me quiero tanto
que quiero verme linda porque amo tanto
este cuerpo que quiero que esté cómodo
en que esté liviano que querer adelgazar
porque me odio porque me carga como soy
y finalmente la comida la convierto en
un castigo no puede ser chiquillos que
le demos a la talla de para los
pantalones a la talla de nuestros jeans
el poder de determinar quiénes somos no
puede ser que le demos a la pesa a una
talla el poder de definir cuánto nos
queremos
el auto amor el autoestima el amor
propio no tiene que ver con auto
convencernos de que somos lindos tiene
que ver con entender que somos mucho más
que eso que somos lo que pensamos lo que
creemos lo que soñamos lo que hacemos
que somos cómo hacemos sentir al resto
que somos lo que provocamos en los demás
que somos nuestros sueños nuestros
valores nuestro trabajo nuestra vocación
y que como nos vemos es un factor más en
esta larga lista de cosas importantes
yo siempre relaciono la cocina con la
felicidad porque para mí relacionarme de
esta manera y sanar mi relación con la
cocina fue también sanar mi relación
conmigo misma con mi cuerpo con mi
imagen y con mi historia hoy día a los
41 años por primera vez me miro en un
espejo y me gusta lo que veo hoy día a
los 41 años por primera vez puedo decir
que me quiero y que me siento
absolutamente orgullosa de la mujer en
la que me he convertido pero yo me
demoré 25 años
y lucha es para que ustedes para que mis
hijas para que otras mujeres en el mundo
para que mi hermana chica no pierda
tanto tiempo en esta búsqueda
la invitación chiquillos queridos es a
nutrir el cuerpo y el alma a entender el
impacto impresionante que tienen los
alimentos en nosotros
qué comer qué cocinar vuelvan a hacer
algo sagrado porque cada cosa que
decidimos comer para alimentar nuestra
mente para alimentar nuestro cuerpo pero
también para alimentar nuestras
emociones somos lo que comemos y eso no
puede ser más cierto cómo nos
alimentamos es una manera de decirle al
mundo cuánto nos queremos es un
manifiesto de lo que somos de nuestros
valores
el gesto primario de alimentarse es un
tremendo gesto de auto amor de
autocuidado y si eso lo proyectamos en
el resto de verdad que es maravilloso
además es una decisión que tomamos al
menos cinco veces al día
esos son 35 veces a la semana son 140
veces al mes
mil 680 veces en un año
imagínense el poder gigantesco que tiene
cada una de esas pequeñas decisiones
[Aplausos]